es la primera vez que el presidente
ucraniano visita una de las zonas más
golpeadas por la guerra volodymyr
selenski llegó este domingo a jarque
para discutir la posibilidad de
reconstruir nuevas viviendas en la
azotada zona del este del territorio
ucraniano según el gobernador cerca del
30% de la segunda región del país está
bajo posesión rusa y más de 2.100
bloques de apartamentos han sido
destruidos por las tropas de moscú que
tenemos que encontrar dinero y líneas de
crédito porque las ciudades los
gobernadores y los alcaldes tienen más
posibilidades de encontrar uno u otro
programa europeo para la construcción de
viviendas algunos programas estatales y
otros locales como su primera salida de
la capital desde la invasión rusa el 24
de febrero se les que también visitó a
las tropas desplegadas en el frente de
batalla las felicito y les mostró su
apoyo
previamente el mandatario pidió a eeuu y
a sus socios europeos más apoyo en
tecnología antiaérea para lograr hacerle
frente a la ofensiva rusa que ha
enfocado sus esfuerzos en el donbass de
una y otra vez recordarle al mundo que
rusia debe ser finalmente reconocida
oficialmente como un estado terrorista y
un estado patrocinador del terrorismo
esto es simplemente cierto es honesto y
refleja la realidad cotidiana que los
ocupantes han creado en ucrania y están
deseando llevar a europa mientras que el
gobierno ucraniano anunció su victoria
ante la ofensiva rusa en severodonezk un
sector clave en la región de lugansk el
ejército ruso se jactó de tener el
control sobre el imán una ciudad del
este de ucrania cuyo control abre la
puerta sobre el dominio del donbass